bienvenue à cette interview sur France
24 et
rfiée le président de la République de
Colombie Gustavo Petro merci monsieur le
Président merci comment allez-vous
concrète vous ont donné les
gouvernements concernés par la guerre
participent ou qu'il la finance assez
peu en réalité
tout d'abord parce que ici c'est un
président solitaire qui s'exprime
les possibilités serait bien plus grande
encore
ou du moins on aurait une vision plus en
noir et blanc comme on dit en Colombie
quand on arrive à conclure que les
puissances mondiales abandonnent
l'humanité
dans une atmosphère de Sauve qui peut
face aux effets de la crise climatique
et au groupe qui ont été les plus lésés
dans la population c'est que leur vie ne
nous intéresse pas
de politique de la mort si vous voulez
c'est une nouvelle fois ce qui s'était
passé au début du 20e siècle mondial
je veux parler de la guerre entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie Lula il y a peu a
déclaré que le président
ukrainien selensky était tout aussi
responsable que le président Poutine
c'est votre avis
au 21e siècle en Irak en Libye en Syrie
il est même qui applaudit ces invasions
en condamne d'autres
il y a de bonnes et de mauvaises
invasions
en fonction des intérêts de pouvoir qui
déterminent la nature de chacune
certaines sont saluées d'autres sont
dénigrés en fonction des intérêts
géopolitiques mais leur responsable
c'est plutôt Poutine que zellinski
c'est une question que je vous laisserai
trancher
nous observons un ou les États-Unis
nous observons un jeu de l'OTAN qui a
favorisé la construction d'une réaction
russe
a eu lieu à l'encontre d'un peuple qui
n'avait rien à voir ni avec l'OTAN ni
avec les Russes il s'agit du peuple
ukrainien ce jeu que l'on essaye aussi
d'imposer dans la région sud-américaine
dont je viens le jeu autant Russie donc
la lutte commerciale entre les
États-Unis et la Chine ne représente pas
les intérêts de l'Amérique latine
à faire c'est de prendre du recul
et de proposer la paix
à ceux du président mexicain et d'autres
gouvernements un appel au dialogue
immédiat à la trêve immédiate et à
mettre fin à la guerre immé nous sommes
disposés à signer
le 4 novembre a été adopté la loi 418
lançant le processus de paix total comme
on l'appelle avec la guérilla de le ln
l'armée de libération nationale la
dissidence des Farcs et les groupes
armés
très concrètement
avez-vous déjà obtenu des résultats
qu'est-ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle le ln conformément à la loi qui
vient d'être signée a choisi des
porte-voix
les négociateurs de leur organisation
ils sont connus sous différents noms
nous avons fait la même chose
ces informations en temps utile nous
n'avons pas choisi de lieu
c'est la prochaine étape
c'est là que nous en sommes
à l'endroit où auront lieu ces
négociations et une fois que les
négociateurs d'un côté et ceux de
l'autre cesseront à la table des
négociations dans ce lieu
avec des pays qui se sont proposés
d'être garant du ce processus entre
autres Cuba la Norvège et le Venezuela
c'est le Brésil également même s'il
faudra avoir comment évolue les choses
après décembre il y a des pays qui se
sont rapprochés du processus
la France vient de me dire que nous
pouvions compter sur le gouvernement
français pour l'ensemble du processus
l'Espagne a également manifesté son
intérêt j'ai même pu rencontrer des
représentants pendant la campagne
l'Espagne a fait figurer le ln sur la
liste terroriste européenne ce qui fait
un certain bruit mais de façon générale
le monde a fait part de son soutien à la
mise en place d'un processus de paix
avec le ln
vous avez rencontré d'importantes
personnalités américaines le secrétaire
d'établi 4 une délégation officielle qui
était envoyé par Biden le chef de la CIA
quelle réponse concrète vous donne
Washington quelle réponse concrète
propose-t-il à votre vision concernant
le trafic de drogue la gestion des
drogues illicides et la question de la
coca je crois que le parti qui est au
pouvoir à l'heure actuelle aux
États-Unis et conscient du fait que la
guerre contre la drogue a échoué
mais dans leur société ils doivent se
mouvoir avec beaucoup de prudence de
précaution mais je pense qu'ils en sont
conscients nous en avons parlé
il y a eu un million de morts en
Amérique latine
des millions de personnes
dont la plupart sont des personnes de
couleur sont passées par la consommation
ou la détention dans les prisons des
États-Unis
qu'autrefois et le célèbre Pablo Escobar
palierait de jalousie devant le pouvoir
d'organisation
donc c'est ma fille qui peuvent armer de
véritables armées un peu comme les
Marines il contrôle des pans entiers de
territoire sur tout le continent ils ont
le pouvoir de mettre à genoux des pays
comme Haïti
je vous prie de m'excuser
capables de tant déstabiliser la
démocratie qu'ils ont fait de l'Amérique
latine l'un des endroits les plus
violents au monde
les États-Unis le reconnaissent et en
même temps la cocaïne tue 3000 à 4000
personnes aux États-Unis
par an
plus en raison des mélanges que pour la
clandestinité de la production et le
fentanil c'est environ 100 000
le président du Venezuela Nicolas
smadoro est considéré comme persona non
grata sur la scène internationale hors
l'urgence climatique nous impose de
sauver la forêt amazonienne vous l'avez
dit et le Venezuela doit faire partie de
cette croisade mondiale pour sauver
l'Amazonie c'est ce que vous avez dit à
la cop27
vous êtes en train d'aider votre
homologue vénézuélien à revenir sur de
la scène internationale en tant que
président légitime pour faire du bien à
la forêt amazonienne mais également à la
forêt des relations diplomatiques
oui
mais pas seulement sur des scènes comme
celle de la Coop mais également lors de
réunions au Mexique
je me rends à une table ronde
pour échanger sur ce sujet avec le
gouvernement français gouvernement
argentin et des délégués du gouvernement
et de l'opposition vénézuélienne
il s'agit ici de s'assurer de trouver
une approche permettant de s'assurer que
les élections de 2024 soit un pacte
social au Venezuela
il y aura des élections en 2024
elle ne doivent pas la santé
menait une polarisation
même si les Vénézuéliens ne basculent
pas dans la violence qui a connu la
Colombie on pourrait assister à des
violences voir des violences armées
c'est que le Venezuela soit en paix
parce que la Colombie peut également
être en paix
de personnes nicolasduro n'est pas le
vrai président du venez à cause des
élections controversées il est soupçonné
de crimes contre l'humanité par les
Nations Unies
est-ce que vous faites c'est légitimer
quelqu'un qui ne le mérite pas quand
dites-vous ce sont des positions
politiques les Nations Unies
reconnaissent Maduro sinon il n'aurait
pas été à la coque on parle de crime
contre l'humanité
les violations des droits de l'homme
qui à mon sens se sont bien produites au
Venezuela
ont été encore pire que Colombie
et ce que je vois c'est qu'on accueille
à bras ouverts des présidents colombiens
alors que des milliers de jeunes sont
morts fusillés par l'armée
lors de la dernière manifestation de
jeunes sans ont été tués et 200 ont été
prisonniers mais que cela signifie-t-il
je l'ai proposé au Venezuela comme je
l'ai proposé à la Colombie et comme je
le propose à l'Amérique latine
il faut renforcer la convention
inter-américaine comme grand traité des
droits de l'homme de la région de
l'Alaska la Patagonie
je suis président parce que j'ai pu
saisir la Cour intérêt américaine des
droits de l'homme
pour protéger mes droits politiques et
si je ne l'avais pas fait j'aurais pu en
être privé en Colombie
je peux dire que c'est une chance car
aujourd'hui je suis en vie et il y a
quelques années le candidat présidentiel
de la gauche aurait été assassiné
voilà mon avis il faut rétablir la
Charte des Droits de l'Homme sur le
continent américain et ne pas faire la
même chose que ce que je vois chez
certains en Europe qui ont applaudit
l'invasion de la Libye et sol ici et
aujourd'hui soumettre des recours contre
l'invasion de l'Ukraine
il faut se poser à l'invasion de la
Libye
à celle de l'Ukraine
de la Palestine à celle de la Syrie et à
l'invasion de l'Irak vous ne croyez pas
s'opposer à l'invasion du Sahara
occidental
ou bien parce que ces personnes ont la
peau plus foncée ou par l'Espagnol alors
ces invasions ne sont pas condamnables
je crois que la Charte des Droits de
l'Homme concerne tout le monde
merci à vous monsieur le Président de la
Colombie merci aux auditeurs de Radio
France Internationale et au
téléspectateurs de France 24